When you actually reach the top, you have to remember you're only halfway there.
You still need to get safely down.
My name is Tapio Alhonsuo from Rovaniemi, Finland, and I'm an ice climber.
When I'm climbing ice, I somehow feel like I need to be some sort of part of the iceberg.
Sometimes, they are angry and they make bad sounds...
...and they try to scare you away.
Sometimes, they have a better mood and you feel more welcome.
When you are ice climbing, you don't see the hold, you don't feel the hold...
...because you have the axe in your hand.
So, you have like a metal prolonging of your hand that you need to feel the ice through.
When you climb a lot, you fail a lot,...
...but you learn how to stand up again and you learn to see your mistakes.
You correct those mistakes and you evolve and progress.